we're told that daryl spent 24 and
one-fourth hours writing a chapter of a
novel
and then they asked us what are some
things that 24 and one-fourth divided by
three-fourths could represent in this
context so
my understanding of this is they really
just want us to
be a little bit creative about what
division by a fraction could represent
in a given context
so
well one i encourage you to pause your
video and think about that a little bit
before i think about it
but one thing
i think about is well
if i took 24 and one-fourth and if i
were to divide it into chunks of
three-fourths of an hour because this is
in hours
how many chunks would i have so
this could represent let's say that
he spent
he spent
45 minutes which is the same thing as
three-fourths of an hour three-fourths
hours of an hour i should say
three-fourths
of n
of
an hour
each
day
how many days
how
many
days
did it take him
did
it take
and then you could evaluate this
24 and one-fourth divided by
three-fourths we've talked about how to
evaluate that in other videos so that's
one context
another one
could be some type of a
comparison
so let's say that 24 and one-fourth is
three-fourths of the amount of time
that he spent doing something else
so let's say so this is now a completely
different context i'm gonna put a line
here i'll do it a different color just
to make it clear it's a different
context
so another one could be to justify doing
this division he spent three fourths
as long
writing
writing
as
he spent
illustrating
illustrating
the chapter
and so then the question is how long did
he spend illustrating
how
long
did
he spend
illustrating
now i really want you to think about
this one my brain actually this one
takes a little bit longer for my brain
to to process but when you think about
it if you divide by a fraction that is
less than one you're going to get a
number larger than the one that you're
dealing with
or another way to think about it the
time spent illustrating
time
illustrating i'll write it like this the
time illustrating
times 3 4
should be equal to the time spent
writing because it says he he spent or
he spent i forgot to write that he spent
three fourths as long writing as he
spent illustrating so time illustrating
times 3 4 should be time writing or 24
and one-fourth
so something times three-fourths is
equal to 24 and one-fourth then
24 and one-fourth divided by
4 should be equal to
time
time
illustrating
so these are the two contexts that i can
think of that might make sense but you
might be able to think of others